You know what I mean?
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in.
Now yesterday
we
discussed
what a person is to do
with respect to any prayer that they
miss.
Now, if a person misses a prayer because
of a legitimate excuse,
they are to make that prayer as soon as
possible. As soon as that circumstance
is no longer there. So, a person sleeps
through a prayer by accident. Person
forgets a prayer by accident. A person
goes in for surgery something
then a person is to pray as soon as they
awaken.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasam said and
and this narration will come up later.
He says,
he said, "Whoever sleeps through a
prayer or forgets it, then he is to make
it as soon as he remembers.
For there is no experation to take its
place, no substitute for making it
except to make it as soon as a person
remembers or awakens or what have you.
Now there is no and what I mean
literally no
possible way there is no
imaginable way that a person
can be conscious
and unable to pray.
As long as a person is conscious they
can pray. Abdullahb
I don't know if many of us have heard of
him he's one of the great heroes of
amongst the companions
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam sent him to a very very evil
man
and the beginning of the fourth year
after Hijra in the month of Muhar this
man was living in the outskirts of Mecca
from Hu and his name was Sufyan Ibal.
Sufyan ibh Khaled was
starting to go around to the various
tribes trying to consolidate all of the
tribes so that they could all attack
Medina at once.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii Wasam
sent Abdullahb alone to deal with him
and Abdullahb
he told he's he's not Abdullahb
doesn't know Soph and so he asked him
how will I know him describe him to me
so I can know him he said when you see
him
you are going to feel
a deep feeling of anxiety
and you will
upon seeing him as shan will come to
mind. This was his indicator.
So when he went he saw him and he saw
him around the time of Assar.
Now the point here is that Abdullah on
was going because all he had was his
sword and he went alone cuz the idea was
to pretend he is part of this
cause you know sign me up. I heard
what you were doing trying to gather
everyone to get rid of this man
speaking about the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam. So I came from far away
to join you.
He said, and this is the point here that
we're making. He said, I feared that
once I engaged with him,
I was going to be unable to pray.
So I prayed as I was walking towards
him.
Where is Abdul? Where is Sophia Khal?
It's probably a few hundred meters away.
You know, between them is desert. So as
he's walking towards him from afar and
he spotted him from afar, he made his
salah he said by lowering my head for
and by the time I reached him I had made
my prayer. Now this was a very
precarious situation
and yet in spite of that Abdullahb
made salah. He made salah there. There
is no possible way a person can miss
salah
beyond the scope of the allowances
that Allah has given
from
all the way till sunset a person doesn't
have 2 three minutes to make salah
impossible
from all the way till a person doesn't
have time to make salah this is an
impossibility so we discussed yesterday
the issue of a person missing prayer
knowingly, purposely without an excuse.
And we said, how does this person make
up that prayer?
Toba. There's no way to make up that
prayer. They purposely took it out of
its time. Therefore, they are to repent
to Allah and to pray many
optional prayers to try to you
know to try to substitute some of that
lost reward and squandered opportunity
but ultimately the person cannot make it
up even if they made a thousand prayers.
Now we are going to transition into
a chapter of the book which is as the
author puts it.
This is a chapter regarding the times in
which a person is prohibited from
prayer.
Now this is a very misunderstood
chapter in prayer in f very
misunderstood by many people and that is
these times which a person is prohibited
from praying.
What is the scope of the prohibition?
What type of prayer are they prohibited
from making? What does this mean with
respect to a person's obligatory prayer
etc. And we will get into all of that
inshallah.
[Silence]
He said
three times meaning during the day and
night in which the messenger of Allah
sallall.aii wasallam used to prohibit us
from prayer or burying any of our dead
during. So, these are three times
throughout a 24-hour period in which it
is prohibited to pray or bury the dead.
He says,
"The first is when the sun first rises
and it is very bright, just peeking over
the horizon. And that prohibition
continues until it rises up. And it is
said that the sun is no longer rising.
The sun has risen. And we'll get into
exactly how long that time is. But for
the sake of the sake of
simplification,
it's about 15 minutes from the time when
the sun first starts to peak over the
horizon, over the eastern horizon.
The prohibition begins at that moment
and it continues for about 15 minutes
until the sun is above the horizon as
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam says
elsewhere
and we will get into that a spears
length over the horizon. He sees
The second time is when the sun reaches
its zenith in the highest most point in
the sky
until
it
moves to the western
side or across the zenith or the middle
of the sky towards the western horizon.
And how much time between when it first
hits the middle, which is exact noon,
exact noon, exact middle of the sky,
until it goes across to the western
side. Roughly 15 minutes. It's roughly
15 minutes. And that is actually until
if we had a stick set up right here and
the sun rose above it when there is no
shade to the stick. If we're on the
equator, if there is no shade to the
stick, that is exact noon. Salah is
prohibited at that time. When does it
when does that prohibition alleviate?
Once it crosses the shade of the stick
is pointing towards the east, the sun is
on the west and there is a few inches of
shade for everything. That is when a
person may pray again. It's about 15
minutes. And number three,
and the third time is when the sun is
just about to set
and reaches that point when it is
beginning to set behind the western
horizon until it is completely gone.
Again, how much time is that? Roughly 15
minutes before the adan of
the same amount of time that we gave the
sun
before or after it
it rises
in the east. We say we allow it to
rise until it is clearly separated and
above the horizon. Right? Same thing
when it reaches that point in the west.
Now salah is prohibited until the sun
completely sets which is about 15
minutes before me. These three times the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
prohibited two things. What are they?
Prayer and and burial. Burial of the
dead. These are these have exceptions as
well which we will discuss. But the rest
of this chapter is going to be founded
and based on that narration of which is
why the author opened with it. And that
narration is found in
just a reminder that tonight there is
the potluck the evening or the monthly
potluck. So I guess bring a pot and
see what you're in luck for. And that
will be after until
also
tomorrow is going to change to 7:30
will be at 5:45
will be at 4:45.
will be at